I'm on page 134 chain-of-command doesn't
apply to other military contractors in
the field I don't see why it should
apply to us caprese sandwich when
they're in actual combat whom exactly do
your heroes report to same person as always. Me.
spicy chicken cilantro wrap
subheading 16 we need a top secret
Yankee white designation for compound
V come on stan. Only one man okays that
you want to stroll into the Oval Office
and start barking orders oh yes
half our own heroes don't know they have
compound V in their veins you want China
finding this one best efforts to limit
collateral damage we'd prefer stronger
wording well a standard language for our
new york contract la Chicago exactly
what casualty allowance are we looking
at here officially zero of course but
cone of silence
34%
veggie frittata
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new boys season 2 video
for home Lander and what's going on with
them talking about the White House the
president so there's a whole bunch of
stuff going on if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I'll be doing videos for all
the episodes during season 2 I just did
a big trailer video so I'll link that at
the end of this to they also just posted
all the titles for the season 2 episodes
but these might not be in the right
order but I got a lot of questions about
what's going on with home Landers
character and what's going on with the
plot during season 2 in the introduction
of storm front so there are a couple
clever things that they're doing during
this opening scene with Giancarlo
Esposito's character talking about
marching into the White House barking
orders telling the President of the
United States what to do you really want
to do that he says he'll yes I want to
do that superheroes in the military was
a big season one plot that was just a
prelude to the real plan that bought
American has putting superheroes in the
White House in the government because
that's where the real power is bought
American is all about using superheroes
to make money they don't care about
saving people or anything like that
superheroes are just a front business
for them as a way to make more money but
really their long game is to actually
take control on a more global scale and
in order to do that they need to take
control of the government so they need
to get superheroes in the government
within the context of the comic book and
the TV show Congress doesn't like
superheroes any more than the military
leadership does so it's another battle
that they have to fight during season 2
and when Giancarlo Esposito is character
is talking about Yankee white clearance
what he's saying is that he needs Yankee
white clearance because of the compound
V stuff is the highest level of security
clearance and background checks done on
someone who works directly with the
president in the vice president of the
United States
it's literally like the highest level of
security clearance you can get next to
top-secret military clearance and if it
wasn't clear they also clarified during
this clip that literally every superhero
is a compound V superhero no superheroes
are born naturally except we just found
out homelander's Son it is possible to
have a biological superhero and pass
that on to someone else but
that point Vogel bomb everyone who
worked inside Vaud American developing
the compound V formula believed that it
was not possible for superheroes to have
children they believe that administering
the compound v two young children young
babies for the most part mostly made
them sterile so they weren't capable of
reproducing then they talk about chain
of command this is another clever
reference to what goes on during the
comic book whose orders to superheroes
follow in the field when they're on
missions Giancarlo Esposito claims that
they report to him what happens though
if they go off the rails what happens
when a superhero goes rogue and they
can't control them that is what people
like black noir are for their
contingency plan he's the master
assassin who's seemingly impervious to
most types of attacks or at least very
resilient against other common superhero
abilities
that's the clever reference to the comic
book storyline for black noir that
they're making with the way that they
edited this opening scene for episode
one of them talking about chain of
command the white house superheroes not
following orders and collateral damage
while black noir is busy taking out this
other big powerful superhero there's
also that cone of silence joke because
black noir never speaks this is what
reference to the old TV show gets smart
because they had a literal cone of
silence joke on that show so pretty much
all superheroes are on Vaud American's
payroll on some level obviously some
superheroes are more powerful than
others you have people like homelander
but then you also have more common
superheroes with just low-level
abilities any time one of those
superheroes doesn't do what Vaught tells
them to do or goes really off the rails
they usually send in people like black
noir to take them out but here's what we
get to home Landers plot during season
two I know a lot of people saw him in
that clip with storm front and they're
like why does he look so different
he doesn't look as big as he did during
season one that's mostly because of the
way they filmed him with that camera
lens it just kind of warps his face a
little bit
he doesn't have quite as much of the
muscle suit on underneath the actual
costume this is the clip of him from
that livestream talking about homelander's story during season 2 like
season 1 was a very externalized sealant
he was really seasoned he was trying to
find his way in the world and it was
very externally focused right his
oedipal complex was fixed by the end of
season 1 so season 2 is about
with the repercussions about that but
then it becomes a much more internalized
journey of you know you've you've you've
taken these big strong actions into you
know I could do whatever the heck I want
and killing mummy figure and trying to
take control without you know with the
sense of autonomy and now you're going to
deal with it so it really is very
challenging for him which makes it a
very interesting season so what he's
saying is is that homelander has
already gone rogue in a big way by
killing Vogel bomb than killing still
well the thing about this though is that
vog American actually doesn't care that
he killed Stillwell and they don't care
about Volga bomb that much either
he had effectively been retired and
already trying to stop bought American
for more crazy experiments with
superheroes and young babies that was
with that whole conversation with
homelander about his son was about why
he hid his son from homelander in the
fate of butcher's wife because he wanted
the kid to have a chance at a better
life than what they did with homelander
when he was growing up there the
reason or at least volga bomb blames
himself for homelander turning into a
psychopath so homelander in a season
two is just dealing with what he does
next now that he's achieved his goals of
season one his plan to put supers in the
military by manipulating the media with
the attacks on the plane i'll laser
every single one of you everybody post
all your memes and he lies about the
foreign superheroes he himself was
partially responsible for creating if
you were confused what's going on here
the reason why this foreign superhero
that black noir is taking out at the
beginning of this episode became a
superhero is because this is a terrorist
cell in someone like a train ran
compound be to them on the dl giving
them this dosage so that they could
create their own superhero to become a
supervillain that would create an even
bigger need for supers in the military
if it wasn't clear during season one
that was not Vaught americans plan they
were actually going the more traditional
route trying to lobby congress and that
just was going super slow homelander
was the one that went rogue and had his
own plan for accomplishing that goal
that's why he was so proud and why
Stilwell was so surprised when he
explained it in the finale so when
Anthony stars referencing homelander
during season 2 about what he does
next now that he really can do whatever
he wants to do as he said during season
one that's where it comes back around to
the even bigger plot to put superheroes
in the White House in the government
going from intimidating the people into
doing whatever he wants to gaining real
power and literally being able to tell
people whatever he wants them to do
homelander for president be sure to
vote this fall
what a coincidence that we are in the
middle of an election year in the United
States I feel like it's perfect timing
for a lot of the storyline during the
boys season too even though that's a bit
of a long game in terms of the boys
comic book if you have read the comic
book careful not to post too many
spoilers in the comments but they are
changing some of the comic book plot it
won't be exactly like it all went down
in the comics but it all comes back
around to this idea of gaining real
power and taking control of the
government
what about storm front though obviously
she's one of the big new characters
during season two she uses social media
in her mind reading ability to control
enormous groups of people that's a bit
of a comic book change too he's more of
a traditional superhero in the comics
that just leads a team called payback
which is a Marvel Avengers Easter Egg
but on the TV show if she's all about
controlling large groups of people and
that's what Homelander is ultimately
trying to do and they're trying to put
supers in the White House eventually if
Anthony Starr mr. homelander himself
says that her character is slowly going
to gain his trust over the course of the
season maybe she's actually viewing
herself as something of a future first
lady to a homelander presidency the
way they talk about both the characters
their utter Psychopaths but they say
that she's way worse than homelander
during season two so everyone let me
know in the comments what do you think
that they're going to change about storm
front in home Landers storyline during
season two and the idea that they want
to put superheroes in the government or
take control of the government
ultimately Eric Kripke the showrunner
for the boys said there be a bunch more
trailers and a bunch more clips coming
really soon so of course I'll do videos
for all that stuff in the new footage
when they drop it the season is starting
September 4th if you didn't see my last
video I'll link that at the end of this
because there's a bunch of other
different footage
everyone click here for that brand new
trailer video and click here for that
brand new Superman man of tomorrow movie
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys
tonight!